Trascrizione: Gianluca Finocchiaro
Revisore:
Buonasera a tutti.
Sono Lisa Bortolotti, il presidente
di Arcipelago SCEC Emilia Romagna
che è una associazione
regionale che fa parte
di un coordinamento nazionale
di 14 regioni in tutta Italia.
Noi ci occupiamo di economia.
Ma non di questa economia,
che sta in questo momento crollando
e non è un'economia che ci piace,
che non è al servizio dell'uomo.
Vorremmo fare, anche un poco
ambiziosamente, una nuova economia
creare un nuovo paradigma.
Per fare questo ripartiamo
dalla ricostruzione delle comunità,
delle relazioni all'interno
delle nostre comunità.
E anche delle relazioni
economiche, perché pensiamo
che mutando queste, possiamo
avere un impatto sistemico
sui nostri territori
e cambiarli radicalmente.
Come fare? Allora innanzitutto
dobbiamo avere un'idea
chiara di come funziona
oggi il sistema economico.
Dobbiamo darci un'immagine
di quello che vorremmo fosse il futuro
qualcosa che ci piace,
ma che ha la funzione di spronarci
a muoverci, per costruire qualcosa
che non possiamo dire come sarà adesso
non possiamo sapere come sarà il futuro
ma ci deve far muovere, far attivare.
E poi dobbiamo creare
una serie di strumenti
che possano aiutarci ora,
in questo momento di transizione
dal vecchio che sta crollando, ad un nuovo
che costruiremo in un prossimo futuro.
Dove siamo ora?
Siamo esattamente qui,
siamo su questa ripidissima montagna russa
e siamo sul picco.
Stiamo guardando il baratro
che ci sta aspettando.
Questa è un'immagine
che mi serve per spiegarvi
l'andamento del debito pubblico.
Noi abbiamo un'economia
che è completamente
monetizzata e finanziarizzata.
Quindi è completamente controllata
dall'andamento di questo debito pubblico
che è una forma tipica a "montagna russa"
si dice una "curva di tipo esponenziale".
Oggi la moneta è diventata una merce,
una merce che ha un valore in sè.
È di proprietà di un soggetto privato
che la emette a debito
che ce la presta molto gentilmente.
Ed è una merce che ha un costo.
Questo costo è il tasso di interesse.
Il tasso d'interesse
che si svolge in relazione
ad un'unica variabile che è il tempo.
E quindi viene caricato
sul capitale esistente,
aggiungendo debito a debito
in ragione del tempo,
a prescindere che noi
abbiamo in mano quella moneta,
a prescindere che noi la usiamo.
Nel momento in cui la moneta viene creata,
diventa un debito a nostro carico.
È una funzione matematica,
una funzione di tipo esponenziale.
Ce la insegnano alle scuole superiori:
è la capitalizzazione
composta dell'interesse.
E come tutte le funzioni matematiche
non ha sentimenti
e quindi non si dispiace di quello
che succede a noi come esseri umani
mentre lei svolge
inevitabilmente i suoi effetti.
E li svolge a prescindere perché
è nella sua natura di funzione matematica.
Quindi qualunque cosa facciamo,
continuerà il suo percorso
fino allo sfracellamento a terra.
Fior fiore di economisti,
di esperti, giornalisti
in questo periodo ci stanno dicendo
cosa dobbiamo sapere, come stanno le cose.
Ma non ci dicono le cose essenziali.
Una cosa essenziale è che
un sistema come questo
è congegnato in maniera geniale
perché possiamo semplificarlo al massimo
- e questo non lo fa mai nessuno -
e possiamo trovare che
abbiamo solo due opzioni:
abbiamo un debito, possiamo
ripagarlo, o cercare di ripagarlo.
È il caso dell'Italia.
Ci sta provando,
ammesso che sia possibile.
Oppure falliamo.
Non riusciamo a ripagare il debito.
La Grecia ne è un esempio,
tecnicamente è fallita.
Ecco il sistema è così geniale che,
sia che ci venga imposta
l'opzione A che quella B
il risultato sarà sempre il medesimo.
Il nostro creditore, che, ripeto,
è un soggetto privato,
non vuole in restituzione
della moneta che ci ha prestato
la stessa moneta, non l'accetterà mai
perché lui lo sa che la moneta
non ha un valore, non è una merce.
Ma vuole quello che noi crediamo di dover
restituire utilizzando la sua moneta.
Quindi beni e servizi reali che facciamo
circolare grazie al prestito che ci fa.
Tramite la cessione
di questa ricchezza reale
il nostro creditore ottiene,
via via nel tempo
la cessione delle nostre sovranità.
Mi riferisco alla sovranità monetaria
che abbiamo perso da tempo,
oppure alla sovranità politica
che stiamo vedendo adesso,
in maniera molto sfrontata
che l'abbiamo persa.
Oppure sovranità come quella della salute,
quella alimentare o quella territoriale
che ci viene sottratta lentamente
nel corso del tempo
e quindi quasi non ce ne accorgiamo.
Cedendo sovranità, chi la ottiene
ha un controllo maggiore
sulle nostre vite.
E quindi ha un potere maggiore sulle
nostre scelte e sulla nostra quotidianità.
E questo avviene perché noi
siamo convinti di doverlo fare
e quindi ogni giorno siamo leggermente
un po' meno liberi di prima.
Un'altra cosa che non ci dicono:
in natura non esiste niente,
tranne una cosa,
che funziona secondo il modello
della montagna russa,
quindi con la curva esponenziale.
In natura funziona in questo modo
la malattia tumorale.
Noi utilizziamo un meccanismo, un sistema
che ha lo stesso decorso
di una malattia mortale.
Comincia lentamente, non ce ne accorgiamo.
Gli effetti si sommano
agli effetti preesistenti
- e questo è l'interesse
che si somma al debito -
quando ci accorgiamo dei sintomi siamo
già nella fase esponenziale
di questa curva
e ormai è troppo tardi perché l'organismo
è troppo infettato, è troppo malato:
ed è il caso delle crisi economiche.
E quando pensiamo di dover far qualcosa
siamo già sul picco, sulla vetta
e non possiamo far altro
che sfracellarci a terra.
E nelle malattie è la soluzione finale.
Quindi, se capiamo che viviamo
in un sistema malato
il buon senso ci dice
"usciamo da questo sistema,
facciamone uno nuovo!".
Ora il futuro nessuno sa
come potrà essere, così come non si sa
cosa potrebbe essere qualcosa di nuovo
perché non siamo abituati a viverlo
non l'abbiamo mai fatto.
Però possiamo prendere esempio
da qualcosa che funziona.
La natura, tornando
al discorso della natura,
ha questa capacità
di avere regole vincenti
Infatti se noi osserviamo gli ecosistemi
ed i sistemi biologici incontaminati
che significa in cui l'uomo
non è ancora arrivato
- vi ho messo il Lago Vostok come esempio
ma ce ne sono tantissimi -
abbiamo ancora la capacità
di osservazione, capiamo
che hanno la capacità
di raggiungere un equilibrio
che vediamo essere prospero.
La natura ha questa particolarità:
raggiungere un equilibrio desiderabile.
All'interno di questi sistemi
che funzionano
i singoli elementi dell'ecosistema
(piante, animali, minerali e tutto quanto)
sanno aggregarsi e apportare
il loro contributo
secondo il proprio codice genetico,
quindi non vanno a scuola
per imparare a farlo,
ma danno il proprio contributo
non perdono la propria identità
e si organizzano
per arrivare tutti insieme
ad un equilibrio duraturo.
Può l'uomo prendere esempio da questo?
Sicuramente sì, può essere uno sprone
a cercare di fare qualcosa di simile.
L'uomo si mette a sistema
quando crea le sue comunità.
Ci hanno infatti detto
che a noi esseri umani
ci piace far la guerra,
che ci piace essere competitivi,
schiacciare il prossimo.
In realtà sempre più studiosi
ci stanno ripetendo
in continuazione che non è così.
Che noi siamo geneticamente progettati
per essere individui sociali
e quindi metterci in comunità
e per essere naturalmente cooperativi.
E quindi generosi.
Quando ci mettiamo a sistema
creiamo le nostre comunità
e spontaneamente cominciamo a lavorare
per l'equilibrio della nostra
comunità e quindi
mettiamo a disposizione
la nostra capacità creativa.
In questo modo cominciamo a produrre
anche beni e servizi per migliorare
il benessere della nostra comunità.
Ecco, quindi,
che viene ripensata l'economia
in un contesto completamente diverso.
Cominciano gli scambi.
Solo a questo punto possiamo ripensare
ad uno strumento di pagamento,
veicolo dello scambio,
semplicemente perché abbiamo
bisogno di ovviare
a quello che è il limite del baratto.
E quindi uno strumento di pagamento
un veicolo per gli scambi
a disposizione di chi effettua gli scambi
non certo emesso a debito
non certo emesso ad interesse.
Ma noi oggi
siamo in Italia.
E dobbiamo fare qualcosa
che sia possibile oggi
nel momento di transizione
e in Italia dove ci sono delle normative
molto stringenti in materia monetaria.
E quindi noi in Arcipelago SCEC
abbiamo pensato al
Buono Locale di Solidarietà
che è un foglietto colorato
e non ha nessun valore.
Viene emesso da una colletività
in questo momento
dall'associazione, gratuitamente
e non è emesso ad interesse.
Non è emesso a debito ed è
di proprietà di chi lo possiede.
Non ha nessun valore, ha valore solo
nel momento in cui si utilizza
perché la sua unica funzione è quella
di essere strumento
degli scambi, esattamente
come il metro per il sarto,
che ha un'utilità
finché serve altrimenti
si rimette nel cassetto.
E non è una moneta,
perché non è convertibile
e non ha nessun valore.
È semplicemente uno strumento.
Come si applica?
Si applica all'interno del circuito
ed è una riduzione volontaria di prezzo
all'interno del circuito
di chi fornisce beni e servizi.
Viene applicato in percentuale
da un minimo del 5% ad un massimo del 30%.
Questo significa ricadere nella normativa
dello sconto incondizionato,
che è esattamente quello che
vi fanno nella grande distribuzione.
La sua particolarità è che
non è uno sconto a perdere,
ma che chi lo accetta, chi traduce
concretamente lo sconto che applica
lo può rispendere.
Ecco perché solidarietà che cammina
perché può essere fatto circolare
all'interno del circuito.
Funzioni ne ha tantissime
all'interno di una comunità
che decide di applicarlo
Una funzione è quella di ancorare
la ricchezza sul territorio.
Normalmente viene drenata all'esterno
tramite la grande distribuzione,
le grandi multinazionali, le spa
franchising, fornitori di servizi.
Tutto quello che noi produciamo se ne va
con questi soggetti.
Mentre ancorando gli scambi sul territorio
possiamo trattenere anche
la parte in moneta
rappresentata da questi scambi.
Quindi liberiamo risorse,
tantissime risorse,
parliamo di cifre grandissime.
E poi sarà la comunità stessa a decidere
come utilizzare queste risorse:
maggiori investimenti,
scelte per sostenere
i bambini piuttosto che gli anziani
ciascuna comunità si riappropria della
responsabilità delle proprie scelte.
Mentre un'altra funzione
che può avere lo SCEC
è sicuramente quella, per la parte
di riduzione di prezzo
che esso rappresenta,
di consentire alla ricchezza reale,
cioè il bene o servizio
scambiato, di circolare
non gravato da debito.
Ma quella parte di bene
o servizio che circola
rappresentato dallo SCEC
manifesta il suo valore esclusivamente
per il valore reale che ha
cioè per se stesso, ricchezza reale.
Quindi qual è il percorso
che abbiamo fatto?
Abbiamo ripensato
il concetto, il paradigma
rimettendo al centro l'uomo
L'uomo che fa sistema,
quindi ricostruisce le proprie comunità
con elementi di relazione con gli altri.
Ripensa l'economia, perché
ripensa gli scambi che effettua
all'interno della sua comunità
e quindi l'economia strumento
al servizio dell'uomo per valorizzarlo
e solo in un terzo momento
lo strumento di pagamento
che, quindi, diventa
lo strumento per lo strumento
e quindi perde di valore in sè.
Ecco, quindi, che
è vero che siamo sul picco della montagna
russa e guardiamo il baratro.
È inevitabile che succeda, è matematico
è nella sua natura.
Però, se ci abituiamo a vedere le cose
da un altro punto di vista,
metaforicamente parlando,
un po' più in là c'è un ponte
che attraversa il vuoto che ci aspetta.
È un ponte piuttosto
agevole da attraversare.
Altri prima di noi l'hanno attraversato
in completa solitudine,
hanno fatto un percorso
ci hanno tracciato la via, però
hanno fatto fatica perché erano da soli.
Mentre adesso abbiamo
la possibilità di unire le forze,
esattamente come fa la natura
con gli elementi del sistema,
ricostruendo le comunità,
ma anche mettendoci in rete
portando ciascuno di noi la propria
identità e le proprie peculiarità,
rafforzando il gruppo e, quindi,
facendo questo percorso
tutti insieme.
Il senso è: è vero
che il sistema crollerà presto.
Però è anche possibile che lo si
lasci crollare totalmente in solitudine.
Io vi ringrazio, questa per me
è stata una grandissima opportunità
perché la considero come
un ulteriore passo verso quel ponte
che intendo comunque percorrere.
Vi lascio con una frase, [che]
mi ha illuminato molto,
di una delle tantissime
studiose che ci stanno dicendo, appunto,
quali sono i nostri elementi,
i nostri punti di forza
per cambiare, per pensare ad un nuovo
lo penseremo come decideremo noi
mano a mano che il tempo
passa, ma che ci sprona
a puntare sugli elementi
di forza di noi persone.
Grazie tante.
(Applausi)